hi everyone and welcome to the itcs 2023
talk on extremo combinatorics iterated
pigeonal arguments and generalizations
of PPP my name is amol prasarker and
this is Joint work with Christos Papa
dimitrio and mihalis yanakakis at
Columbia University
so I'd like to start by emphasizing that
in this talk we will primarily be
concerned with search also known as
function problems where the objective is
to search for a certain certificate as
opposed to Simply decide whether or not
the certificate exists as we would in a
decision problem
the major function problem classes
include FP and FNP and these are the
search analogs of the more widely known
decision classes p and NP
here F in FP and FNP stands for function
the TF in tfnp stands for total function
problems the word total here signifies
that these problems are guaranteed to
have a solution
the NP in tfnp signifies that these
Solutions are also polynomially
verifiable
and to make this formal we can say that
any tfnp problem is given by a
polynomially computable relation R and
this relation takes us input X and Y
here the x is going to denote the
problem instance and the Y is going to
denote the certificate and the key
property of totality with r is that for
any X any problem instance there exists
a y which is a certificate such that X
comma y belongs to the relation
and the actual tfnp problem in this case
can then be articulated as follows
you're given an input X and the task is
to find a y such that X comma y belongs
to the relation r
now an interesting motivation for
studying tfnp comes from the following
dilemma
on one hand there are problems in tfnp
for which we strongly believe that
there's no polynomial time algorithm in
other words we believe these problems
are not in P one classic example of this
would be the problem of factoring
on the other hand we can't appeal to the
theory of NP or in this case FNP
completeness to provide evidence that
these problems are not in p and the
reason for this is if any of these tfnp
problems actually were FMP complete it
would imply that NP is equal to co-enp
so to address this we need to actually
introduce intermediate complexity
classes that are in between FP and FNP
and these are the so-called FNP
intermediate complexity classes as you
see in this figure here and these
intermediate classes are going to be
used to characterize the difficulty of
many of the problems in tfnp
so to build on that while it's extremely
unlikely that we would have tfnp
complete problems there are many notable
subclasses of tfnp and there's a very
subtle point to consider here that the
problems in tfnp are by definition total
and this means that there should be a
mathematical proof of totality but note
if the mathematical proof was
constructive that is if it describes a
procedure for generating the certificate
for a problem then we can simply follow
that procedure in an algorithmic way and
efficiently find the certificate in
polynomial time this would place the
problem in FP
but we believe a lot of these problems
are not in FP and the hardness of these
problems in tfnp comes from the fact
that the mathematical proofs of totality
are actually non-constructive that is
they don't show you how to actually
construct the certificate at least in an
efficient way
and in line with this uh Papa dimitrio
Johnson nyanakakis and others in the 90s
sought to organize the problems in tfnp
based on their mathematical proofs of
totality
and each subclass of tfnp embodies uh
one of these mathematical proof methods
so here are some examples uh the class P
the class PPP embodies the pigeonal
principle and we're going to talk about
this in great depth shortly
the class is PPA and ppad embody a
combinatorial principle which we'll call
the handshaking Lemma
and the class PLS captures The Challenge
from optimization of finding local
Optima
um and then in this talk we're actually
going to introduce a new class in the
tfnp world which we're going to call PLC
which stands for polynomial long choice
and this class embodies a similar but
more expressive argument than PPP which
we'll call the iterated pigeonal
principle
so as we're interested in the pyginal
principle a natural starting point then
is to discuss the class PPP which stands
for polynomial pidginal principle
this class is defined in terms of its
complete problem pigeonal circuit and in
some papers you're going to hear this
problem called Collision
um and in this problem you're given a
polynomial and N size circuit which Maps
the integers from 0 to 2 to the N minus
1 and this is typically given by a set
of n bit strings so they're represented
efficiently
um and it's going to map this set to
itself
and the challenge is that you either
want to find a element that maps to zero
and X such that P of X is zero or you
want to find a collision
and it's it's straightforward to see
that this problem has to be total
because on one hand if you have a zero
element then you're done you have a
certificate but if you suppose instead
that there are no zero elements that is
there's no element X such that P of X is
equal to zero what this in turn tells
you is that every single element
um in the in the domain of p is actually
mapped to a value in the in the range
one through two to the N minus one to
make that more concrete that means that
there's 2 to the N elements in the
domain that are being mapped to a set of
size 2 to the N minus one by the pisnal
principle there has to be a collision
so we then defined the class of problems
that are polynomial polynomially
reducible to a pyginal circuit
um as the class PPP
um and of course uh I'd like to
emphasize that uh this problem is hard
because the function is represented
concisely by by a polynomial in a
circuit whereas the search space is
actually exponential in N of course if
we're given an explicit representation
whose size matches the size of the
domain then the problem would be in p
and to see why we could then check every
combination of inputs until we found a
zero element and we could do that in
polynomial time or zero element or a
collision to be clear
so uh interestingly the the pigeonal
principle that we just talked about is
is just one counting argument in the
much broader field of extremal
combinatorics and the idea is in
extremely combinatorics typically
encapsulate the following General
phenomena that if a collection of
objects becomes large enough there has
to be some structure that exists and
with regards to tfnp we're going to
focus on three themes and the
corresponding lemmas and extremely
combinatorics each Lemma gives rise to a
corresponding tfnp search problem as
we're going to see so first we're going
to look at problems whose totality is
based on an iterated pigeonal principle
argument and these are the problems
which belong to the class plc
uh the underlying lemmas include the
sunflower Lemma as well as Ramsay type
theorems
second we're going to introduce new
problems which are PPP complete and this
includes problems based on kanig's Lemma
and the erdish Colorado Lemma
and third we're going to consider
problems that are harder than PPP
because of the way in which they're
encoded and in this setting we're going
to consider problems based on toron type
theorems
so without further Ado we're going to
start by discussing problems involving
an iterated pigeonal principle argument
so we're going to start by introducing
this game that will refer to throughout
this talk and this is a really
interesting two-player game and uh in
this game we're going to start with two
to the end pigeons and player one is
going to start by picking a single
pigeon
um this Choice can be arbitrary
and it's going to leave 2 to the N minus
pigeons left in the game
and at each round player 2 is going to
partition the remaining pigeons in the
game into into two groups and the player
one is then faced with a choice player
one has to pick a pigeon from one of
these groups and upon doing so a player
2 is going to remove the pigeons from
the other group of the um from the other
group entirely from this game so every
every at every round
um there's going to be some set of
pigeons that are that are going to be
removed from the game
and the game ends when there's no more
choices that player one can possibly
make
um so if we want to think about the
objectives in this game uh player one
um has the objective um player one wants
to play this game for as many rounds as
possible
in other words player one wants to pick
a long sequence of pigeons whereas
player two actually wants to make this
uh impossible and player two is going to
partition the pigeons at every single
stage in such a way that player one's
options diminish as rapidly as possible
so the question then becomes what's the
optimal strategy for player one and it
turns out that there is an optimal
strategy wherein at every round player
one picks a pigeon from the larger
majority side of this partition that
player 2 creates
and by doing this uh player one is
guaranteed to pick
um up to n plus one different pigeons
to see why we just applied the
positional principle at every stage
and we can use the bound induced by the
pigeon principle to argue that as so
long as player one is picking from the
majority there's going to be a certain
amount of pigeons left and we can
continue this argument for end stages to
get to a final result of n plus one
pigeons
so we're going to call the argument
that's used here the iterated majority
argument
so we can turn this game into a tfnp
search problem if we if we equip player
2 with a suite of polynomial time
algorithms and these are adaptive
algorithms and the challenges are
successfully generate a sequence of
length n plus one as player one and in
fact this is how exactly how we're going
to define the problem long choice in
longchoice
and the universe of objects corresponds
to pigeons and the circuits Pi represent
player 2's algorithm at stage I of the
game note that the circuit Pi takes its
input all of player one's choices up to
round eye of the game you can see this
by noting that play that Pi the the I
function takes as input I plus one
inputs and the First Eye of these are
the choices that player one has made up
to the stage of the game
and you know that the circuit Pi takes
us
um a constant value so essentially the
the circuit Pi takes uh this this added
restriction here that um the sequence
that we generate Pi has to be constant
um over this this input for all um AJ
greater than a i
and uh this is an interesting kind of
condition to enforce but this condition
really is trying to uh enforce the
concept that player one can only pick
from the remaining pigeons from our two
player game
um so the challenge again for player one
is to generate this long sequence of of
objects from this universe and um we
should take a pause at this point and
think about why this problem is actually
hard
after all we did give a seemingly
constructive procedure for player one to
win the the two-player game that we
described and long choice is really just
a formulation of that two-player game
um and uh a big challenge a big
challenge here is that estimating the
majority of roughly two to the N
elements
um or estimating the majority at any
stage of this game
um in poly end time is extremely hard
and the reason for that is because
um the number of available objects that
you can use to continue this
construction
um in other words the number of objects
that player player one can continue to
add to this sequence diminishes rapidly
if player two
um you know plays optimally and um as a
result it becomes hard to not only
estimate the majority but it also
becomes hard to pick an element from
this majority and these are both things
that player one has to successfully do
to solve this problem
so again the hardness here comes from
the fact that the problem instance is
represented concisely using circuits
and if we were given an explicit
representation this would just again
this problem would be in P or FP
so we Define the the class PLC to be the
set of problems reducible in polynomial
time to Long choice
um and we note that the totality again
entirely follows from the um totality
argument the iterated majority argument
that we just talked about
so thus far we've discussed PLC and
longchoice as well as PVP and it seems
that PLC captures this iterated majority
argument which involves an a repeated
and an Adaptive use of the pigeonal
principle so then it shouldn't be too
surprising that PPP is actually
contained in the class PLC and to prove
this we simply reduce the PPP complete
pigeonal circuit problem to the PLC
complete long Choice problem and to do
so we construct a universe for our long
Choice problem which is just a domain of
the circuit from the pigeonal circuit
problem
and player 2 given by the functions Pi
Place restrictions of the following kind
they force any valid long Choice
sequence to have the property that later
elements in the sequence have closer and
closer images
and if we Define the functions Pi
appropriately then these functions
guarantee that any long Choice sequence
is going to have the property that
subsequent elements in the sequence are
closer and closer together under their
mappings via the pigeonal circuit and by
the time you get to the end of this long
Choice sequence the elements are going
to be so close together that they'll
have to collide with at least one other
element in the sequence and that
Collision is going to give you a
certificate to positional Circuit of
course to see the full proof
um it's in the it's in the paper but
that's the general outline
um and of course I'd like to note that
um we think it's unlikely that PLC is
equivalent to PPP for the same reasons
we discussed that there's a there's an
Adaptive component
um and a majority estimation procedure
that's not quite there in the more
static PPP
so another combinatorial result whose
proof uses the iterated majority
argument is Ramsay's theorem and the
version of the serum that we're going to
discuss here is as follows you have a
complete graph of size R to the RN and
you color each Edge using one of our
colors uh there must be a monochromatic
click of size n according to Ramsay's
theorem and there's an iterated majority
argument at play here as well
so to sketch the beginning of this
argument we can repeat the following
procedure up to RN plus one times uh you
pick a random vertex and then you
partition the remaining vertices based
on the color of their Edge to this
vertex and by the pyginal principle
there must be at least R to the RN minus
1 vertices whose edges to this first
node have the same color and what we're
going to do is we're going to keep all
those vertices and discard the rest
and then we're going to pick another
vertex from the remaining set of
vertices and we're going to repeat the
exact same procedure starting with this
second second node
and we can repeat this procedure many
times and the resulting structure that
we're going to construct in this process
is going to be awfully similar to Long
Choice the long Choice certificate or
the sequence of pigeons as we talked
about and the idea then is that you can
take that that structure and then you
can quickly use it to construct a click
um
and essentially that's the that's the
proof and um you can then you can take
the problem the tfnp problem based off
of this Ramses theorem which is a graph
essentially given implicitly by a
circuit of polynomial size and this
circuit is going to take two nodes as
input and it's going to Output the color
of its Edge
so this uh this graph is going to
implicitly Define an edge coloring on
the complete graph of size R to the RN
um and the challenge of course is to
find a monochromatic click of size n
and based on the the proof of totality
that I just described we can actually uh
use that proof to directly encode this
problem as a long Choice problem so
there's a pretty straightforward proof
essentially that R comma n Ramsey
reduces to Long choice and therefore
belongs to plc
so another related result from
extremical combinatorics is the
Sunflower Lemma to introduce this result
we should first look at some notation we
call a caseet system a collection of
sets all of which contain K elements and
in the figure on this Slide the
rectangles here
describe sets of size three
so we can refer to them as a three set
system
a sunflower is a collection of sets with
the property then that every pair in the
collection has the same exact
intersection
and in the figure you can see an example
of a sunflower these sets all contain
the same value in common all their
pairwise intersections only only contain
the value two so this this forms a
sunflower and the reason that we call
this a sunflower is actually visual in
nature you can think of the common
intersection going to the center of the
sunflower and the petals contain the
disjoint components of each set so for
example this set 15 5 and 2 the 2 goes
to the center here and the 15 and the
five go to the The Petal
thank you
so the sunflower Lemma is going to argue
that a sufficiently large set system
must have a sunflower and it's important
to note that the extremal bounds
provided here are actually not the
strongest known to date particularly
this bound here
um
and uh in in past years there's been
breakthrough work by Alice and others
that have significantly improved this
extremely bound however we can still
meaningfully work with these weaker
Browns as they give rise to still
provably hard tfnp problems which I'll
talk about in a moment
foreign so we're going to formulate this
problem naive sunflower here
um and this has a weaker extremely bound
than what we described in the previous
slide which is why we call it naive
sunflower and we note that uh this this
bound doesn't actually diminish the
hardness of the problem
um it's just still hard we can prove
this under cryptographic assumptions
specifically under the assumption that
Collision resistant hash functions exist
and in this problem we're given a kset
system with K cubed times log K cents
and we'd like to find a sunflower of PSI
is K squared
um this set system is given implicitly
as usual by a poly case I circuit and
concretely it's going to take as input
and index and it's going to Output a
corresponding element of the set system
so it's going to actually output a set
of size
um of size of size k
so now we provide a detailed proof in
the paper that uh naive sunflower
reduces to Long choice and the key
Gadget in this proof is this result by
Desa that describes how to characterized
sunflower as a combinatorial structure
as a collection of pairwise equidistant
points in a metric space and to do this
you can take any two sets and you can
define a distance between them as the
size of their symmetric set difference
uh this is a valid metric and under this
metric sufficiently large sunflowers are
equivalently characterized as
collections of pairwise equidistant
objects
and using these correspondence we can
then take a a set system and we can
convert it to a graph where every single
node in the graph corresponds to one of
these sets and we color The Edge between
any two nodes based on the diff the
distance between the underlying sets
that these nodes represent
and if we take this approach a click
then corresponds to a collection of
pairwise equidistant sets and therefore
the problem of finding a click helps
allows us to find the sunflower
so this line of reasoning shows that
naive sunflower actually belongs to PLC
um since Ro comma n Ramsey belongs to
plc
so the reduction essentially takes naive
sunflower reduces it to R comma and
Ramsay in this case it reduces it to
square root of n comma n Ramsey so R is
equal to square root of N and that
problem then directly reduces to plc
so we've shown that there are indeed
um interesting problems in PLC all of
PPP Ramsay and sunflower
and what we're going to consider here is
a dual argument of PPP and this gives
rise to an empty positional principle
argument
if I have a few pigeons and
um many more pigeon holes no matter how
how I place the pigeons into a
pigeonhole there must be an empty pistol
the search problem here is to find the
empty pigeonole and this idea was first
introduced in the work of metropolski
court in kleinberg and Papa dimitrio and
they Define this problem empty given
here it was very similar to pigeonal
Circuit the only difference is that the
um this this concisely represented
circuit c maps a smaller input space to
a larger range
in particular it excludes the element
zero in the input space but the zero the
element zero is is actually included in
the output space here
um so the challenge becomes to find an
element in the output space that does
not belong to the image of the input
space
um so certainly such a problem exist
which makes this total
um and we Define the class P Epp to be
or pep to be the set of problems
polynominally reducible to this problem
empty the question then becomes how do
we know that such an empty pigeon exists
um unfortunately it's not very clear how
to um how to polynomially verify that
that a empty positional is indeed an
empty pigeonhole the only way we'd know
how to do so would be to actually check
every single input and map the input
through C but doing so requires
exponential time so there's a kind of a
quantification that's that's at work
here
and this problem actually belongs uh
it's a total problem that belongs to the
polynomial hierarchy TF Sigma 2p
so in the same way that pep is the a
dual argument of PPP we can consider
also a dual argument of long choice
and we Define a problem which we call a
short choice and it embodies this dual
argument where if we recall the
two-player game from from the beginning
of this talk player one wants to pick as
many pigeons as possible in that game
and therefore player one is going to
pick from the majority
If instead
um player one wants to terminate the
game as quickly as possible they can
actually repeatedly choose from the
minority
and this argument is called an iterated
minority argument and the short Choice
problem encapsulates this challenge
and we're given a standard long Choice
problem but with slightly fewer elements
in particular
2 to the N minus two elements in the
universe
our goal is to find a short sequence
then which cannot be extended that is
some sequence of elements a0 through a k
with the property that they satisfy the
conditions from long Choice imposed by
the function's pi but we can extend this
sequence in One Direction either zero or
one and the challenge is to find both
that direction as well as this sequence
and the totality follows from this
iterated minority argument that I just
described
so accordingly we can Define the class
PSC polynomial short Choice as a set of
all search problems that are polynomial
time reducible to short choice and in
the same way that PLC is more expressive
than PVP we can use a similar dual proof
to show that short choice is actually
p-e-p-p hard and in in that sense pep is
included in the class PSC
the open question then becomes what are
the natural problems that belong to this
class PSC
thank you
great so that's why we've discussed
problems which involve the use of the
iterated pictional principle and now
we're going to discuss other problems
from extremely combinatorics which are
actually PPP complete
we'll start with Canada's limo on a
binary tree and this essentially states
that if you have an infinite binary tree
there must exist an infinite simple path
from the root of the tree
this seems like an obvious statement but
it's instructive to consider how the
pigeonal principle actually plays a role
in proving this fact
so interestingly the proof method
closely follows the iterated arguments
discussed thus far
we started the root and we note that at
least one of the left or right sides of
the binary tree contains infinitely many
nodes by the pictional principle
so we can proceed in that direction and
then we can repeat this argument on that
subtree and we can repeat this Forever
Until We yield uh this infinite simple
path
the canic problem considers a finite or
extremal case here wherein we have a
binary tree of size 2 to the unknowns
and we're asked to find either a simple
path of length n plus one from the root
or to find a violation of the binary
tree structure I'll note that the proof
of totality I just should suggest that
the problem belongs to PLC which it is
but interestingly the problem is
actually PPP become complete and I'd
encourage you to check the paper for the
full details
another result which we consider in this
work is the errors from extremo set
theory and as with the sunflower Lemma
in this setting we're considering caseet
systems however the question is slightly
different
it is how large can a case that system
with the constraint kind of case it's a
case at system B sorry with the
constraint that every pair of sets has a
non-empty intersection
so the errors Colorado Lemma states that
if the universe has more than n minus
one choose K minus one sets uh where n
is the size of the universe
there must be two disjoint sets
and we can correspondingly formulate a
tfnp search problem as follows given a
cases system consisting of more than n
minus one choose K minus one sets
the problem is to find two disjoint sets
if they if that's uh if they exist or if
they don't exist there must be a
violation of some kind the problem must
be ill-formed um in particular there
should be either you know for example
two identical sets or an invalid coding
of a set
and an important detail to keep in mind
here is that this problem
um again as we've seen with with tfnp it
amplifies the hardness by changing the
size of the universe to be exponential
in the size of the problem
representation which is polyan poly M
sorry
um so this is something that we've seen
with all the other problems and and this
is exactly the same same construction
here
and uh of course in this problem we've
we've simplified where K is actually
equal to two here
so what we find is that um if we have a
circuit
um that is able to generate um this this
uh this this collection of key sets
then this this problem
um eres Colorado is actually PPP
complete
great now we're going to discuss a class
of problems which Define hierarchies
that go beyond PPP and their source of
hardness arises in uh in a sort of
um from the indirect way in which the
problems encode the problem instance
so
we're going to start with discussing a
kind of yet another flavor of graph
problems which I'll refer to as Tehran
type problems and we're going to start
with a simple case of this
mantel's theorem which states that any
triangle-free graph of n vertices can
have at most n Over N squared over four
edges
and to understand this extremely
threshold of N squared over four it's
useful to consider the case where you
have a complete bipartite graph of n
over two vertices on each side that's
that is you have n over two vertices on
each side of the bipartition and you
generate every single allowed Edge
between the these these two groups of
vertices that that gives you N squared
over four edges
now tehran's theorem addresses the more
general question of how many edges can a
K plus one click free graph have
um rather how many edges can a graph
have
while simultaneously being free of
clicks of size K plus 1.
and ventils Theorem refers to the
special case of k equals 2 of course
and the extremal case here is pretty
similar to mental's theorem we're going
to consider a complete K part type graph
with n over K vertices in each partition
and to generate all edges in this K
partition the the way you can think
about this is there are K choose two
ways to pick two partitions and then
once you've picked these two partitions
you there are n over K squared edges
that you can generate between the nodes
and on in these two sides of the
partition and therefore K choose two
times n over K squared is kind of the
expression that you get for the maximum
number of edges you can generate in this
setting
here
so we can formulate a search problem
that uh is structured as follows if you
cross this extremal bound that I just
described then there must be a click or
there must be some related violation
and as usual we're going to consider
implicitly represented graphs so instead
of considering n vertices we're going to
consider 2 to the N vertices
um
or other graphs of size to the N
vertices
and the the problem is going to
essentially say that uh you have this
efficient circuit or this efficiently
represented circuit and it defines
um K choose 2 times 2 to the N squared
plus one edges and this is a graph of
um K times 2 to the N vertices so this
expression exactly mirrors the extremal
bound that I just described and we're
going to cross that external Bound by
adding one extra Edge
and the way this circuit functions just
to be clear is it has an input a concise
index and the output is going to Simply
Be a pair of vertices
um each vertex is represented by the
logarithm of this so n plus log K bits
and the challenge is again to find a
click or to find some invalid
formulation of this problem this is
essential to keep the problem total
so what we find is is really interesting
is that PPP reduces to tutoron and then
there's also a hierarchy where every
successive value of K is kind of a more
General version of this problem so K to
run reduces to K plus 1 to run for all K
greater than or equal to 2. uh and we
believe that this problem is um is
harder than these problems are all
harder than PPP and they're harder than
each other because at each successive
stage of this hierarchy
um there's a more and more indirect
encoding of the problem instance and
that indirect encoding for information
theoretic reasons uh makes the problem
harder than um than uh than PPP
great so this this work uh raises many
interesting questions some of which
we'll list here we've considered this
large class of tfnp search problems from
extremely combinatorics and many of
these problems Inspire the definition of
new classes like PLC and then PSC
and intuitively it seems that PLC and
PSC are significantly more expressive
than PPP and pep
however it would be interesting to see
these black box separations that
actually provide further evidence of
this uh this uh separation and hardness
and it would also be very interesting to
see more natural complete problems for
these classes
and finally as mentioned we've
considered a variety of extremal
problems here but the hardness of the
tfnp problem is is connected with the uh
strength of the extremal bound so it'd
be interesting to see further analyzes
of tfnp problems that have stronger
external bounds
okay and uh thank you so much for
listening